well big cat a week ago today you and i
were discussing how this dislocated
kneecap suffered by patrol homes on
thursday night football would impact the
balance of his season and you made a
very good point i'm reluctant to give
you credit but i shall that if there's
any risk you shut him down for the year
because this is going to be your
quarterback for the next 15.
but there he is on the practice field he
practiced wednesday and thursday limited
and now that question still lingers
could he actually play on sunday night
this is a three to six week injury and
he could be back in only 10 days after
having that kneecap and in the spot
where kneecaps aren't supposed to be
your thoughts on the possibility they'll
actually put him out there
if they put them out if they put patrick
mahomes out there on sunday night they
should be uh put any real read should be
put in jail i'll say that right now andy
reid should be put
back
listen you're changing all the rules of
society my guarantee counts as two
losses and if you put them on the field
you get put in jail mike
have you looked at what the afc
playoff picture looks like the kansas
city chiefs are not going to get home
field advantage it's not going to happen
they're not going to beat the patriots
they play the patriots once the patriots
are not going to lose enough to have
home field advantage okay
look at the afc west the chargers are a
dumpster fire the broncos are a dumpster
fire the raiders they're up and down but
they're probably not going to be
competitive enough to challenge the
chiefs for the afc west look at the rest
of the afc you have the ravens guess
what the chiefs beat them head to head
of course the cults have looked good and
the colts beat the chiefs head-to-head
but what my point is you can do
very little and get in the playoffs this
year in the afc especially with the
talent the chiefs have otherwise so to
risk patrick mahomes long term for a
game that is you know you're playing
against a hot aaron rodgers you might
lose it with patrick mahomes in there is
absolutely insane they should make sure
that patrick mahomes is 100 healthy
before he comes back because the chiefs
can win the afc west probably at nine
and seven mike and that's really all
that should matter at this point get in
the playoffs and have patrick mahomes
healthy figure it out then you're not
going to get a buy or you might get a
buy but you're not going to get the home
field advantage so say goodbye to that
just get into the playoffs
i think what they're trying to do is
preserve the buy they have to worry
about the ravens they win the tiebreaker
with the ravens but the problem is they
would lose the tiebreaker with the colts
or the texans so they're trying to nail
down that buy and i think that the
method to this potential madness and i'm
with you i don't think they should plan
if he's not 100
i think they're tempted to put him back
there and basically stand on one leg if
you need to we know how he can throw the
ball if he's got no feet on the ground
just let him throw the ball and if
there's any danger you just take a knee
i don't like it i don't like it but i
feel like they're they're at least
seriously considering doing it we'll be
right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports